you better cover up young lady you might
get just called
what am i thinking today we're talking
the worst reviewed superhero movies in
infamous league of rotten films that
scored less than 20
on the tomato meter if you don't have an
identity why keep it a secret
because you killed me
[Music]
it was me you flushed down the pipes now
there are plenty of poorly received
superhero movies out there but for this
list if the film doesn't accumulate at
least 20 critics reviews it won't be
included but don't worry there are
plenty of familiar films on this list
from marvel to dc and even a few movies
that flew under the radar two million
you don't have it three million i'll
borrow it from you four million
five million that's a utility belt not a
money belt six million
seven million
so without further ado let's count down
the worst reviewed superhero movies ever
[Music]
starting with number 10 jonah hex
having cheated death gunslinger and
bounty hunter jonah hex has one foot in
the natural world and one in the
supernatural his unusual nature gives
him the ability to track down anyone or
anything so the army makes him an
irresistible offer it will erase the
warrants on his head if he will find
quentin turnbull now turnbull his oldest
enemies preparing to unleash hell on
earth and we'll stop it nothing to kill
him starring josh brolin john malkovich
megan fox and directed by jimmy hayward
critics say josh brolin gives it his
best shot but he can't keep the short
unfocused jonah hacks from collapsing on
the screen
can you shoot
can you
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
always do lack when you finally show up
number nine superman 4 the quest for
peace
seeing the united states and the soviet
union engaged in a nuclear arms race
that could lead to earth's destruction
superman decides that he must take
action now he collects all the nuclear
warheads from the world and throws him
into space meanwhile superman's nemesis
lex luthor has broken out of prison with
a new scheme he clones superman with
radioactive material to create nuclear
man a being just as powerful as the man
of steel starring christopher reeve gene
hackman muriel hemingway and directed by
sydney j fury critics say this franchise
bottoms out with superman 4 the quest
for peace the action is boring the
special effects look cheaper and none of
the actors appear interested in where
the plot's going
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number eight the crow city of angels
after a mechanic ash and his son witness
a murder they are captured and killed by
drug lord judah soon a young artist
named sarah meets ash who has just
returned from the dead now sarah who had
known a man resurrected into the
vengeful warrior the crow years ago
explains to ash that he is now the crow
ash sets out to get revenge by slaying
judah and his minions but judah
discovers the crow's power and craves it
for himself starring vincent perez mia
kirschner richard brooks and directed by
tim pope critics say the crow city of
angels is a sloppy pretender that
captures neither the mood nor energy of
the original
i'll stop looking emo
and then work my way up the food chain
where is it
he's an old pervert he hangs out of the
people around on deacon street
congratulations
you just bought yourself a fight intense
lady ducks
you're wasting your breath from genito
nobody's up there listening
[Music]
number seven elektra
assassin for hire elektra works for a
mysterious international organization
known as the hand for which she kills
her targets without question and in a
conspicuous red bustier no less now when
the hand asks her to kill mark miller
and his daughter abby while they're on
holiday elektra's conscience kicks in
and she decides to protect her targets
rather than eliminate them of course the
hand isn't so willing to let them off
the hook starring jennifer garner
terrence stamp kirsten prout and
directed by rob bowman critics say
jennifer garner inhabits her role with
ernest gusto but elektra's tone-deaf
script is too serious and bereft of
intelligent dialogue to provide engaging
thrills
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
i told you
there's nothing you can do
[Music]
number six supergirl
cara of argo city poses as clark kent's
cousin linda lee to recover the omega
hedron from a witch starring helen
slater faye dunaway peter o'toole and
directed by jenot zwark critics say the
effects are cheesy and supergirl's
wide-eyed cherry heroine simply isn't
interesting to watch for an hour and a
half
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number five catwoman
catwoman is the story of shy sensitive
artist patience phillips a woman who
can't seem to stop apologizing for her
own existence she works as a graphic
designer for hidari beauty a mammoth
cosmetics company on the verge of
releasing a revolutionary anti-aging
product but when patience inadvertently
happens upon a dark secret her employer
is hiding she finds herself in the
middle of a corporate conspiracy what
happens next changes patients forever
starring halle berry benjamin bratt
sharon stone and directed by pit off
critics say halle berry is the lone
bright spot in catwoman but even she
can't save this laughable action
thriller
you're just a scared little girl playing
dress up
[Music]
you're gonna look like a cop killer
you wanted to save him honey
you couldn't save yourself
[Music]
number four fantastic four
transported to an alternate universe
four young outsiders gain super human
powers as they alter their physical form
in shocking ways reed richards becomes
mr fantastic able to stretch and twist
his body at will while pal ben grimm
gains immense strength as the thing
johnny storm becomes a human torch able
to control and project fire while his
sister sue becomes the invisible woman
together the team must harness their new
abilities to prevent doctor doom from
destroying earth starring miles teller
michael b jordan kate mara and directed
by josh trank critics say dull and
downbeat this fantastic four proves a
woefully misguided attempt to translate
a classic comic series without the humor
joy or colorful thrills that made it
great the franklin storm research center
dad was kind of allergic to his name in
big letters which reminds me i think
that the four of us should have a name
why would we need a name because we're a
team now and there's four of us so we
should come up with a name for it
[Music]
like the human torch in the torchettes
oh no you kidding me
how about the big brain and his neurons
how about the big brain and her neurons
how about two guys a girl and the thing
that nobody wanted
hey we both know that you could take him
hey hey what
come a long way since the garage
gotta say
it's fantastic
say that again
[Music]
it's fantastic
yes it is
number three son of the mask
a cartoonist and family man tim avery
lives a peaceful existence with his wife
tanya as well as her infant son and dog
now when the curious canine finds a mask
with mythical properties both dog and
baby create chaos with its powers while
tim and tonya try to contain the damage
the sly norse god loki comes looking for
the artifact resulting in more mishaps
that ultimately incur the wrath of the
deity's powerful father odin starring
jamie kennedy alan [ __ ] ryan falconer
and directed by lawrence gutterman
critics say son of the mask is overly
frantic painfully unfunny and sorely
missing the presence of jim carrey
[Music]
[Music]
don't you just love halloween
[Applause]
trick-or-treat
arti-har let me see your work id please
[Music]
id no id
no party where did the wife put that
invitation
[Music]
id
not iv excuse me
my bad
maybe i left in my other pants
[Music]
okay
number two zoom
captain zoom or jack as he is now known
has long since given up his career of
fighting evil and protecting the
defenseless the former superhero gets
back into the game when he takes a job
at a private academy where he must whip
into shape a ragtag group of heroes in
training starring tim allen courtney cox
spencer breslin and directed by peter
hewitt critics say lacking the punch and
good cheer of the incredibles and sky
high zoom is a dull laugh-free affair
[Music]
[Music]
just like riding the bike
[Music]
is that it
is there anyone else who can face me
i'm still standing here you little twerp
sir i wouldn't do that
what's that sound
hey it's jackie
[Music]
actually
it's zoom
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
batman and robin
this superhero adventure finds batman
and his partner robin attempting to foil
the sinister schemes of a deranged set
of new villains most notably the
melancholy mr freeze who wants to make
gotham an arctic region and the sultry
poison ivy a plant-loving femme fatale
now as dynamic duo contends with these
bad guys a third hero batgirl joins the
ranks of the city's crime fighters
starring arnold schwarzenegger george
clooney chris o'donnell and directed by
joel schumacher critics say joel
schumacher's tongue-in-cheek attitude
hits an unbearable limit in batman and
robin resulting in a frantic and
mindless movie that's too jokey to care
much for
[Music]
we have less than 11 minutes to call the
city
[Music]
wow
gotcha
[Music]
shield
[Music]
steel former army scientists one in a
steel suit team up in los angeles
against another who turned bad starring
shaquille o'neal annabeth gish judd
nelson and directed by kenneth johnson
critics say steel is a badly acted movie
that indulges not only in superhero
cliches but also the sappy tv movie of
the week ones it's on now
all right
[Music]
[Music]
hey
we're switching you get killed out here
[Music]
howard the duck
in this film based on the comic book
character howard the duck is suddenly
beamed from duck world a planet of
intelligent ducks with arms and legs to
earth where he lands in cleveland now
there he saves rocker beverly from thugs
and forms a friendship with her she
introduces him to phil who works at a
lab with scientist dr jenning when the
doctor attempts to return howard to his
world jenning instead transfers an evil
spirit into his own body starring leah
thompson tim robbins chip zine and
directed by willard hewick critics say
while it has its moments howard the duck
suffers from an uneven tone and mediocre
performances
they just spotted the duck and the kid
where behind the warehouse next door
they're about to take off what do you
mean take off
it's not doing anything cops
[Music]
there's right everywhere in the air
howard up up
[Applause]
[Music]
follow him bring him down and bring him
back
and finally number one max steele
teenager max mcgrath discovers that his
body can generate the most powerful
energy in the universe now steel is a
funny slightly rebellious techno-organic
extraterrestrial who wants to utilize
max's skills when the two meet they
combine together to become max steel a
superhero with unmatched strength on
earth they soon learn to rely on each
other when max steele must square off
against an unstoppable enemy from
another galaxy starring ben winchell
maria bello josh brenner and directed by
stuart hendler critics say bereft of
characterization or even satisfying
rock'em sock'em max steel feels like
feusting with an action figure without
any childhood imagination
[Music]
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and for
even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time i'm
your host naz perez and we'll see you
back here for more top 10s on the rotten
tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you